[Música]
como rubén díaz muchos son muy jóvenes
vinieron el cierre de campaña del
candidato a diputado ultra liberal de
derecha el economista javier mi ley y
están desencantados con la política
tradicional argentina
vi que encuentra una solución en el
tiempo en el que yo actúe
[Música]
digo básicamente y también mis padres
contándome con lo que pasa el pasado es
ver como constantemente se repite el
ciclo ellos creen que billy con su
política de mínima intervención estatal
ayudará a impulsar leyes para lograr una
estabilidad socioeconómica en argentina
una alternativa a la que se vuelca una
parte de una opinión pública saturada
tras años de descontento como señala el
consultor jorge giacobbe una opinión
pública que votó un presidente con el
48% en algún momento
tuvo de él un 68 por ciento la imagen
positiva y hoy tiene un 15 demuestra que
el nivel de ofensa un nivel de
desconexión un nivel de descrédito que
es enorme
desde la vereda opuesta a mi ley la
coalición del frente de izquierda
también se ha posicionado como
alternativa entre quienes están cansados
de las que consideran desacertadas
decisiones de los partidos tradicionales
con el gobierno de ahora
[Música]
si bien no se espera que ninguna de
estas terceras fuerzas desplacen las
urnas a la coalición gobernante del
frente de todos ni a la oposición de
juntos por el cambio si las está
obligando a prestarle atención a esta
fuga de votos por izquierda y por
derecha si estas otras propuestas
llegaran a crecer en las elecciones del
domingo podría leerse como una evidencia
de que realmente existe una crisis de la
actual hegemonía política en el país
vigente desde hace casi 20 años